Classical music plays
intense music plays
tropical music plays
Hey!
Welcome!
To Sanic Spin... 2006
Oh, boy...
...are we spinning...
Oh, God that's creepy.
Heh pew...
Heh
You wanna buy some drugs?
Alright, TRIGGER WARNING
TRIGGER WARNING!
That's gonna spin a lot. Alright?
If you get motion sick, you might throw up.
Alright? So make sure that you haven't eaten anything before you watch this.
Have you eaten anything?
That's cool. Let's go.
[Spinning and spinning and spinning...]
[still spinning]
*throws up* (not really)
Let's go, next level.
Yeah!
Best game!
(Let's Get Physical plays)
It actually looks like a Sonic dildo.
I just realised.
Okay, the levels are getting harder.
And so is the dildo.
Oh, god!
Fucking hell, this is disorienting.
Oh my god.
I've always wanted to be a Sonic penis in space.
In the sky.
Hey, this is pretty good!
Here we go!
Oh god!
Oookay.
Fuu-
How ha- How has sonic not killed himself already? Goddamn this is horrible.
Here we go.
Goddamn, I'm legit starting to feel sick playing this game.
Honestly, how do you bros feel right now? (not good honestly)
I feel like the first time I played a Sonic game.
Aroused.
[What the actual fuck]
[Oh, god.]
[Pewds fanfictions]
music continues playing
Goddamn it.
I get so fucking easily motion sick.
What I didn't do it, are you kidding me?
Fucking jump in the circle you fucking s-
Sonic asshole. There we go. Thank you.
Oh hey-yey! Hehey! Look at that!
C'mon Sanic!
(laughs)
Is that the winning Sanic?
How did I do it the other time?
(bursts out laughing)
What a fail!
Oh, for fuck's sake!
Wait, that was it?!
Are you kidding me?!
I NEED MORE!
[Turn down your volume right now]
I need more! [RIP headphone users]
What the fuck?!
[badly timed sanic ear rape warning]
(Sad music plays)
When you run out of Sanic. There's only one thing that you can do.
I'm sorry, father.
I'm sorry.
I need to do it.
Uuhm
Alright. Well let's move on the next game.
[dramatic music playing]
So this is a game about putting stuff in your mouth
so this is a game that i can really relate to
[music plays] yeah
oooh this is some dANk 420mlg shit
pewds is stripper
press start [whistle]
OH GOD what the fuck happened, what just happened [deez nuts happened]
WHAT JUST HAPPENED!!
I CAN'T
OHH UH ITS GOING IN
[LIGADWGIA] OH GOD IT WENT IN THE SIDES
WHAT THE F*CK AM I LOOKING AT
[clapping]
is that a panda?
oh my god this is fucking disgusting
I love it, keep putting shit in your mouth
holy shit this is the greatest game. i've never said that before so you know it's legit
put the banana inside yo- uuhguhdh it tastes good
tastes good
You're right it tastes good. hah.
YEAH YEAH YEAH THAT'S IT BABY
YEAH THAT'S THE WAY I LIKE IT
okay wait lobster, lobster get in there ya bitch
oh god the PANDA WITH A HAMBURGER CAN WE DO IT
COME ON PANDA
[burping and retching sounds]
get inside my mouth baby (malcom1466)
ye- thats right
oh god a shark oh e- its a f*cking whale and a sausage at the same time
i have never enjoyed a game this much
Eat it ya fucking bitch. EAT IT
*sad music*
KILL ME
*dramatic music*
*pewds burp* The reason you clicked on the video. Let's go.
One Night Stand. We're playing .... One Night Stand
Now I've never had a one night stand. *silence* *ok Pewds*
Yes mom.
That sounded weird. *laughs*
So I don't know what to experience but it - oh you haven't-you haven't either?
Oh well let's experience a one night stand ... together.
Sounded weird again. Whatever let's do this
Oh... Alright so it's all blurry... so it's like a point and click game -ummmm- I heard
eh bros this was 3 free games with pewds even though it was 6 but it doesn't matter
leave a like if you enjoyed (write #cutieduckpiezia if you read subtitles)